definitely uh want to want to talk about
it while we still can and if we if we go
on strike we'll pack up and go home well
we're here we're uh we're ready to show
the film and uh we have an incredible
cost who feel very strongly they want to
promote the film but uh with an
impending strike you know we're just
trying to do what we can before uh
whatever happens
what solidarity with our side colleagues
so we will we will be with them uh with
our Fellas on a 33-year member of The
Guild so I think this is a critical
moment and they're working super hard to
try and reach an agreement a fair one
for everybody there's an existential
threat to you know the industry that
needs to be addressed it's being
addressed it's painful process but it
has to be done we won't be able to
almost gone through this uh but it's you
know that's the way that's the way to
cooking crumbles